[Music]
thank you so that the title is having
fun with new music and caris that's
actually what we are going to do we are
going to now let's see and let's have
some fun so my personal motivation so
why am i am i interested in music so I
play guitar myself and I had spent when
I started just started playing the
guitar I spent hours and hours listening
to records finding out what court was
being played over and over and over and
over again it was horrible then during
my studies as as physics then I learned
that there is something like a free a
theory which can decompose a signal into
all the frequencies I thought okay I'm
there I just applied this free itv2 to
my favorite records and I can just
generate my scores from it it turned out
to be a little bit more complicated than
that and actually now since we have this
the neural networks and deep learning we
can actually start going in that
direction and actually finally starting
to achieve where I actually want it's
already 16 years ago so what are we
going to need to do today so for I'm not
going to download some music black chaos
to it and say hey this is nice result so
instead we're first will build up a
simple simple synthesizer and we're
using numpy for that so you can also
easily do it yourself and and and and
experiment with that so I will also
explain a little bit of I call it music
theory but just a little bit of how to
generate some music and actually we use
simple random number generation and use
that to to generate like an infinite
data set with with music that sounds it
sounds like music it's not it's not
something you can can sell or anything
but it's just nice datasets and I will
use this generated data for some deep
learning applications and I'm mainly
going to dive in on operations on the
raw sound data so
I'm not going to do anything with MIDI
generation so typically a lot of the
work nowadays is with MIDI and generates
actual music like the that sounds nice
I'm mainly going to focus on the raw
audio signal and how to process these
events so why would I take this approach
why generate the data set if you can
just scrape Spotify or whatever then you
could well first of all it's more fun
this way so we can actually start
building a synthesizer in Empire right
and since you're building it from the
ground up
we actually have also enough to turn the
complexity so I can start with just a
single instrument I can add a second two
instruments I can add harmony I can just
have the whole spectrum of complexity
that can slowly switch on and last of
all the data set of generative music is
unlimited so we never run out we have
infinite amount of data so so I've
actually done so we have we'd go to a
derivative we have these Friday's I've
actually worked on three cases but I
probably have only time to present the
first one and that's to single out an
instrument when multiple instruments are
playing together and so we have a song
with multiple with guitar and and some
other instruments can we just get a
guitar back and the other case that I
also worked on is to detect notes when
they're being played and it's actually
my initial thing that I was after at
it's called solfege and that's for a
single instrument and then also I want
to extend that model to to use multiple
instruments and to actually split it
split the whole the the the total
waveform into the different instruments
with each instrument its own score and
on the real music so this is on
synthesized music and on real music
we'll actually also as a teaser we will
try this final part so we have a full
band playing and we just get the guitar
back
so let's start building the synthesizer
and but before we do that let's take
step back who has worked with audio
before okay so a lot of lot of people
still learn something new
so whenever so let's first I fear a wave
file I'll read it in with using a nice
function with with side by and I get to
thing if you do that you get two things
back a sample rate and a raw data and if
you look at the sample rate is forty
four hundred forty-four thousand one
hundred and that's the number of samples
per unit per second and Siddiq this is
typical for CD quality music so this is
what you will typically see if you you
will load it like that then if we look
at the raw data we have this we have
just if you look at the shape we have a
1d array with a lot of these samples and
so here you have all the samples that
are in there if we just have so sooo min
on to a small portion of it we see a
bunch of integers so what do these
integers mean so these integers are
actually the position the intended
position of your loudspeaker at that
point in time so whenever there's a -
it's on one side of the the equilibrium
position and this is just the position
of your labs the internet position of
your loudspeaker of course your
loudspeaker is not completely 100%
linear and it will have its own effect
on the music as well but this is sort of
the idea of music this is the encoding
of your of music so as I said we have
these integers of course we can convert
these integers back to floating point
numbers and have a little bit of more
easy way to interpret it like one means
the maximum for volume and - well so one
means the maximum volume and also when
we start using deep learning it helps to
have it actually skilled in the unit
domain also to note is that if we are
using music if we're looking at
music and we having a sample rate of
forty four point one kilohertz we're
actually the highest tone in there is
half of it and actually if you look at
what frequencies people can actually
hear the highest frequency that we can
hear is roughly for young people 20
kilohertz and so that's it means that if
you go above it you you will not change
it will not change the music by a lot
although there are some interactions
between different frequencies so let's
let's do the normalization to unit
domain already explained so typically
you can divide by the max but it's
better to actually divide by the max in
notes by the next thing that you've seen
in the in the in your data so this is
how it looks like this is four five
roughly five minutes of music and a nice
fair way if you are ever going to work
with audio in jupiter notebooks there's
this I bite and don't display
functionality and it adds a very nice
widgets you can see it the over here you
can just put in some array say which
separates was associated with it you can
just play it
[Music]
this is now between 40 and 50 seconds
this is the part that you basically saw
here so let's go to the next one let's
zoom in one second this is how it looks
if we zoom in even further so you can
already see that this is not an easy
signal right this is a it's a lot of
noise
everything is encoded just you music to
me is very multi-dimensional right you
have frequencies you have you have
movements and stuff like that but
everything is encoded in just this one
that is one dimensional string and how
do you get it out right so that's the
challenge that we're up to so let's
start building it now from the ground up
let's start with building a simple
synthesizer
let's first generate a tongue and let's
start with the sign we have a sign over
there we generate a data frame put the
time in as a as a grid of sample rate
and generate a sign like this this is
everything that we're doing then I made
a like a for now I've made three graphs
so here you have all this old data if
you zoom out over like I think one
second then this is how you zoomed in
and into 0.02 seconds and this is a
spectral graph this is this
multi-dimensional thing that I'm telling
about so you have basically frequencies
on this axis and you have time on this
axis and whenever it lights up it means
this frequency is active so if we're now
if we're now generating one single tone
it means that we indeed have a one
straight line that we see in the
spectral graph and you can actually I
already mentioned the spectral this
Fourier transform you can actually get
the spectral graph by doing a free eye
transform so for so if if I just want to
detect which note is being played by the
simple synthesizer I could actually use
free eye for this and because I can just
pick up the max frequency over here I'm
done
okay let's now add an envelope to it so
I'll have the sign over there I multiply
it by an exponential as you can see over
here then it looks like this as zoomed
in it's still extremely flat but you
have this envelope on a slightly larger
time scale also in frequency you see it
slowly dampening you get a little bit of
sort of a boring electric piano sound
right
let's continue so so we just generated
one single sign but actually if we add
multiple signs to it with with an
integer multiple of the original
frequency so we have a sign over there
twice and triple the frequency over
there then those frequencies are called
harmonics so we have a fundamental
frequency which is the lowest and then
every multiple integer multiple of that
is going it's going to be an harmonic
and if you actually add those two
together that will actually not change
the periodicity of the the slowest
signal so you will still perceive it as
having the same pictures original so
I've made this function additive
synthesis takes in a grid of T values a
grid of amplitudes frequencies and faces
and you're going to basically add those
signs together and here I just picked
some random values for amps random
integer multiples for the frequencies
and I'll put all the faces on 0 a
journal generated and you get it
slightly more complex waveform over here
but you can still see and hear that it's
the same pitch as we had before it's
slightly more a slightly brighter more
aggressive and indeed let's show this
was the original sign this was the
original sign and this is the edited
sound so it's more bright as more more
field to it also very interesting our
ears are not susceptible to face so if
we actually instead of these phases we
put R and
uniform phases in it we can actually see
that we have a totally different
waveform but our ears actually don't
hear the difference the same way and and
on the so if you might hear some
differences is due to the non-linearity
of the speakers but so there's there's
because actually this has a higher
output but so this is this is quite
quite quite amazing and if we now apply
a decay on this additive sound we get
something that sounds like this we're
starting to get a slightly less boring
electrical piano noise and we can get
one so let's also use a little bit of
drums so I will generate a kick drum
which is basically I will generate a
frequency that starts very high and then
decays to a low value so the frequency
will decay like that and it will also
employ fly over that that tone will also
apply this exponential decay and then
we'll see how that sounds so this is how
it looks like so you have you can
actually see that it's slowly so this
kick drum now let's go one further with
one step further let's generate a snare
drum so snare drum let's start with
generating noise so be prepared for
noise so this is noise let's add some
decay and the tone of the original bass
drum that we had and let's combine those
together with an exponential decay as
well there we have it
[Music]
so this is there's another technique
that's called subtractive synthesis and
the basic idea is you start with a
waveform that's not not signed for
instance in this case I use a square
waveform and then this square wave
waveform has already a lot of frequency
content in it as you can see you see all
these lines in the spectrogram and it
already sounds very well very 8-bit
right Mario computer game or something
and then the idea is that you actually
so there's a it sounds a bit harsh
because there's too many frequencies in
there so actually the idea is that you
subtract frequencies from the spectrum
like here so you will actually say all
these these higher frequencies I will I
will just damp them I will remove them
and if you do that so you can already
see here they are sort of removed you
actually get a slightly different
waveform in it and it sounds a bit a bit
more dark bit more friendly right these
are these synthesizers I will actually
use for generating the music just to
mention that we have just only scratched
the surface over here so there's a lot
of things that you can do to make it
nicer you can add effects like
Distortion bit crushing delay reverb
scores stuff like that you can there's
even a different totally different way
of FM synthesis where you that looks
like it's difference and then you have a
synthesis using sampling where you
actually put a piano sample in it and
you compress it so we'll get higher
frequencies and there's also physical
modeling where you actually model the
the string of pianos and modelled
resonances within a piano for instance
and you can also use LFOs for modulation
effects so there's a whole field on
itself but let's now generate some music
so this everyone knows this this is
piano keyboard there's 12 notes one
thing I want to stress there's 12 notes
if you count them and you get to the
same pattern again and then repeat
repeats and repeats so actually if you
look if you take this formula to the to
the twelfth power you see that you
actually get a doubling of the frequency
so it gets actually you're making a
harmonic step so and that sounds very
similar to original notes so this is
also it's easy to implement all the
frequencies of all the notes on a piano
by just using this formula and you have
to sort of tune the the original you
have to tune it using some basic
frequency and typically we use 400 for
440 Hertz for that so I made a small
class that actually takes all this does
all this work for me so I created here a
note class you can see it as a frequency
440 and we can also generate the
frequencies of different notes and it's
just implementation of that formula I
also made a small function that
generates and the signs for me
so I don't have to do it anymore so he
can just generate a note takes a note in
and generates it this a D and of course
if I can generate a D I can also
generate a skill like the or any
facility doe and here those are the the
notes that belong to it and I just
generate the full two octaves that's to
two times the repetition and I'll
basically
[Music]
it's a bit loud on that side or could I
still improve my synthesizer of its or
okay so given that we have notes there's
also their medical there are music rules
for making chords out of notes and given
that same progression of notes I can
generate a chord that fits along with it
[Music]
so that's so we have something that's
already music let's try let's try to
make a basic improvisation and we'll use
a random walk for that so but first I
want to have some chords something that
that's that makes the music a bit nicer
I keep this one fixed and this this
chord progression I take which is one
that's used most in pop music and that
sounds like this
[Music]
probably all know one one song that
immediately fits within this a chord
progression there's so many out there so
now add some melody melody as I already
said I will use the random walk but then
through the skill because the skill sort
of governs with notes pits in which fit
nice together and of course since we're
doing a random walk I can also decide on
if I want to make big steps or small
steps and stuff like that so I made a
sort of tune to taste no ml or no even
statistical analysis involved there just
to tune these weights or for making
smaller and bigger steps by hands so
these are the the probabilities that I
used and then basically I also I don't
want to continue growing up into
infinite [ __ ] so so I also sort of a
mirrored whenever I was out of some
range and a predetermined and how does
that actually sound like
[Music]
they'll not make me rich but but but but
I do have I have an infinite data set
this way actually I hate this music by
now I've heard it so often this so let's
go to the three case where I'm will be
filtering out the melody from the
combined sample so we have this model
we're going to make a model that will
take this input wave with three
instruments and we'll generate out only
the melody part so actually if we look
at it it's very much almost like an
outro encoder right it's not exactly
Auto encoding but we have this some
original data going in then we have some
dense network in between and we can
generate the output again but this is
then a different output so let's try it
so this this will be our input data will
look like this
[Music]
at a baseline as well
and then this is our target so the motor
will just try to predict from X train Y
train so so how do i generate actually a
training set from it so I cannot just
put in the full sequence of data because
that will be too much right so I have to
sort of break it up into small batches
so what I actually do as I generate like
30 seconds or 12 12 minutes or data and
then I randomly sample some portions out
of it and then that's how I actually
generate the training sets so let's try
let's try to make the simplest model
that that I can it can come up with just
a dense model so on
one one thousand data points slightly
more let's just connect a dense model to
it and so you can see here there's just
a dense layer then prelude activation in
between we get indeed slightly we are
going to reduce the reduce it by a bit
and then we're scaling up again to at
least have the same output dimension as
our input dimension how does that
actually we didn't train we just
initialized some random weights so how
does it actually sound
not not particularly nice right
so this is what to random this sounds
like let's try to fit the model and
actually used only to epochs for it
and let's test the model so this was
original and this was the reconstructed
could be a bit better right
not not particularly nice but let's
let's first try if it's over fit it or
not so we are going to generate a
completely new data set in a different
key with a different different different
scale even so actually so it it's it's
not remembering actually all the samples
that it has seen of course but still of
course if you would put some real music
to it it will it will be over fitted on
this particular sound sounds of the
dataset okay let's so this is sort of
working but can we actually make it
slightly better if we get this thing to
the top so we had actually a very simple
why isn't that working let's try this
one no that's one it's working so we had
to think it's still on so let's now
instead we know about this free a
transform right so we have this one the
sample one the stream of data which
contains all the information well we
have this Fourier transform that
actually sort of makes it way more as
how we perceive music and also our ear
is constructed in a way to detect these
things so it will help us to actually do
that so let's let's try that out so
again we're using the same train and
targets I will not explain that for you
and this is the what I call the FFT
branches model so we start with the
input
we then do an FFT within the model
itself then we get a dense network on
the actual values of the the spectrogram
the the highlights but then the Fourier
transform also gives you information
about the phases of the of the signals
but as I said we don't hear these phases
so then so this is on the so then I can
construct again for ya the the the the
inverse Fourier transform and that will
be finally my prediction so only here
are going to be the weights of the model
so and actually so I will not go through
it completely but I've put it here you
can actually see that you it's not so
hard to do a Fourier transform within
your network you can just do that by
using tensor flower functionality so
let's continue so again how does it
sound before training not so much
different
and then let's continue so actually I
needed here
to do more than to eat to epochs because
yeah I just need it and so let's let's
actually start testing it before
and after actually it was I was actually
happy when this happens I thought hey
this is and this might be working and
well let's try again on this different
data set works as well so I was thinking
can I actually do this on the real music
can I actually do this full band with
two guitar can just using the same
structure so now this will be our
exchange you can beat our an event
and then the only two guitar
[Music]
and then use that to fit it and will it
still work
so this reconstructed you can fill here
a little bit of the drums but it made me
really happy when this I go through this
level there's there's just one
disclaimer that if you use this and you
also learn a lot about the backing track
in itself so there's also if you use
this on a different piece of music you
will still see that it it has some
issues with it
it's finding out what is actually the
internet guitar but it's a very nice
starting point there's one last thing
that I want to do too to try out so if
we use the model train on the
synthesizer and we use that for the same
purpose does it actually work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can definitely see that all the
drums are still being fed through the
network right so it's not being filled
with this whole so the drums were not
part of my synthetic data set so that
you can imagine but still the the it
picks up the more the guitar from from
the music then did the rest of the music
so it's already add it's already sort of
gets the notion of the the main
instrument the melody line out of it so
conclusions so actually so what I really
think what I really liked about this
project is that I created some
playgrounds where I can tweak my
complexity of my things that I'm working
in myself and typically we download the
data set we apply some deep learning on
it and then we see oh it's not working
or it is working and then someone it's
it you learn a lot from actually playing
around with it and make it being able to
tweak the complexity because the and
actually I've been able to use
techniques that I learned here at the
customer as well and by just being able
to explore getting better insights on
these algorithms so that's my main
takeaway for you and that was
you